oh no oh no that's true okay so today we
are gonna melt all 100 chocolate bars
into the one epic chocolate bar
hopefully let's get started
movies to the side oh no oh I've got a
little bit of water which I'm gonna
start boiling how do I start this thing
I know cool so I guess I'll just start
wrapping chocolates I'm just gonna chat
with pasty moving Matt a tasty producer
should just pop in to make sure I'm
doing this right okay wow this is a lot
I didn't know that there was this made
candy bars in the world I don't want to
mess it up you don't mind helping no I
loved it they start throwing wrappers on
the ground okay oh wow you know what a
lie they're supposed to be candy bars
york that's kind of it
your weird flavor yeah this is not gonna
taste good I don't think oh I've been
very excited about this yeah are we
being exciting and fun it's time to
start giving it a little bit of a mix
okay it does look like literally yeah
but it'll taste good this one is chili
so it's me a little bit fighting this
one has corn flakes in it open company
that's like bringing back my childhood
insecurities I'm not being able to open
up watch you do it in one check on ones
right
[Music]
we're on the homestretch we are and I'm
ending with good ol Three Musketeers
all right classic I think that should be
stirred but I don't think it all fit so
why don't I get another book Wow
potential so I'm gonna back up and shoot
but um once this is fully melted for
that one into one of those and then let
them chill in the fridge for later right
yes please do
chuckle it's two chocolate soup you guys
wanna try it so delicious hey things
like frosting mm-hmm being fit in this
we're just gonna do it there's some
interesting chunks at the bottom of this
some wafer some peanut you're right this
is a good size I get this one to go in
this one does have different bars you
can tell all right put it in the
refrigerator
chuckle 'it is getting cold I'm gonna
melt this chocolate I don't have
anything to say why is melting
Oh
it's solid yeah I will just rest down my
bump and then head off
I don't feel super good about this next
step let's go upstairs maybe Matt will
be there and he'll help us we found him
he's helped here he's making sushi yes I
think I need a big sheet pan yeah oh
wait I'm so you're taking the one from
the freezer here okay oh yeah look at
that
let's put like a little cool of it in
the center I'm feeling good I think
we're good to go
oh wow
coming oh is pretty on this side now I
think you should do the honors
okay Wow worked out like the right
amount how did that happen so now I say
that we've put it into the fridge so
you're gonna come back and eat it in an
hour
um I will try part of it tada
Matt come look at this it did crack a
little but you know I still feel like
it's beautiful yeah alright going for it
mmm great oh do I feel if I do it's like
a chew me on the info this is delicious
oh it's kind of peanut buttery I'm
getting coconut too
oh yeah oh it's pretty great legit good
yeah today what like when the day
started I did not expect to be here yeah
but we did it and it's like actually
pretty impressive mm-hmm
kind of over chocolate right now though
yeah I don't ever want to see it again